- Was it always theater for you, though?
Or did you
are you really into TV as well?
- Oh, I was a latchkey kid
so we watched
- Oh, me too.
I watched, you know, far too much TV.
- Me too, but look at us now! (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- I know.
You know what I'm saying?
- They say TV's horrible for you!
But I'm thinking we're successful.
We didn't end up hoodlums.
It's fine (laughs).
- Yeah, I used to watch um,
I guess it was so bad or good
however you looked at it like,
t.v. sitcoms and stuff
are still a huge comfort to me,
like, when I go to sleep and stuff
I can like,
- Nostalgic.
- Yeah, just put on an episode of Cheers
and like,
- Yes!
The theme song puts me,
- I know all the theme songs.
- Do you really?
- Don't you remember, like,
I mean I feel like there was a time
when like every show it was like
the theme song was huge for the,
- Had a great theme song.
- Yes!
♪ Making your way in the world today ♪
♪ Takes everything you got ♪
- Yes!
I didn't know all the words
see I retain nothing.
♪ Singing ♪
But I know Norm,
and I know the whole cast. (laughs)
You know what my favorite was,
wait, what was the one where, um,
they had the guy, Urkel?
They had, um, what was it?
Family Matters, but what was
that song, and then that one lady
that went like
♪ Ahh-Ohh. ♪
Like in the song
(audience laughing)
That was my favorite one
cause she was just like wailing
and I was like I wanna be her!